we're seeing record prices again this
month with their median sales price
jumping to 475 from 460 last month
that's uh up more than 26 percent from
this time last year um not sure about
the sustainability of it i foresee
and many of the national experts have
said that
we should see a slowing in the increase
of prices through this year still going
up but not at the
percentages of last year
some of the biggest challenges for new
home buyers entering the market is
number one the growing price increases
and but number two is is the rising
interest rates uh that changes the
affordable affordability of the housing
in fact some of the statistics we show
that housing has increased your monthly
payment has increased over 48 percent
from this time last year
with the increase of the price and the
increase of
the interest rate and we're seeing
across the country a lot of the same
issues
affordable housing or workforce housing
is a big one
building building properties
is not happening fast enough we're
seeing inventory restrictions are all
all across the country which is creating
big price increases
and affecting
affordable housing really